lucca so hat heute besonders viel um die
ohren letzter garderoben check für die
sängerin die gleiche ins mainzer
unterhaus kommen wird nervös ins nichts
und ist jetzt auch mit anfangen würde
hektik zu verbreiten
dann wird es ganz schlimm so viel
betriebsamkeit war nicht mehr seit der
schließung im november gleich soll ein
video gedreht werden um damit spenden
einzusammeln zieles drei monate
sicherheit früher war mehr glitzer
regeln und kurzarbeit erschweren die
abläufe so muss der leiter des
unterhauses stephan denzer selbst regie
führen
vorher aber noch mal kurz ins büro der
auftritt eines künstlers für 20 21 muss
noch gesichert werden alle theater
machen in deutschland das gleiche sie
schieben veranstaltungen nach hinten und
es gibt nur eine begrenzte anzahl von
künstlern die dafür in frage kommen für
die theater also bald sich jetzt vor uns
allen so eine riesen bugwelle von
künstlern die alle gerne haben möchte ab
dem herbst 21 das ist ungefähr das was
man sich das vorstellen muss und das
macht die situation sehr schwierig
viel arbeit trotzdem musste das haus
zwei mitarbeiterinnen entlassen kosten
senken
jetzt aber nach vorne schauen immerhin
bekommt heute ein junges talent einen
auftritt wir ham uns erst einmal
natürlich entschieden weil wir hier
lokal denken auch eine junge künstlerin
aus mainz zu nehmen die das spielen wird
lea hieronymus ist musicalsängerin sie
soll jetzt für spenden werden
oh ja dann kommen mit deinen schritten
mal vorbei
[Musik]
ich habe ja ein comedy programm
geschrieben und wollte mich auch im märz
damit selbstständig machen und durch
bewohner hat das ganze dann nicht so
funktioniert ich hatte meine premiere
jetzt erst im september hier im
unterhaus es ist total schade weil man
hockt zu hause rum und nicht irgendwas
produktives tun muss aber einfach halt
warten bis die theater wieder aufmachen
deswegen ist es halt so schön dass man
wenigstens an solchen dingen wie heute
teilnehmen kann schnell zurück auf die
bühne unterdessen muss luca caso den
licht assistenten geben dass benjamin
bringt meiner zuge der muss immer für
alles nicht ich weiß ganz neue aufgabe
also eigentlich meine aufgabe
betriebsleiter und wie wird immer
erklärt betriebsleiter muss gucken das
alles macht die aufgaben wachsen in
corona zeiten mit corona ist es halt
schwierig ist es anders zu arbeiten ich
war jetzt auch das letzte jahr unter
anderem oben im büro und habe da das
alles mitbekommen mann hatte man als
geplant wo man so wusste dass es
eventuell sowieso nicht abfinden kann
das hat halt allen auf die stimmung
geschlagen irgendwann ist halt ins büro
gegangen dachtest du wozu noch den
ganzen blödsinn durchziehen luca so
schlüpft in die nächste falle
wir können hier rausgehen wenn wir kurz
aus dem rauch so rausgehen dann ist mir
das auch recht nur dass ein bisschen
luft drin haben bitte er ist auch corona
beauftragter des unterhauses
matthias wasser oder muss so zur sucht
können wir das ist so meine hauptaufgabe
das ich gucke das immer wieder gelüftet
wird das alles was hygiene punkte sind
dass ich die einheit war weil manchmal
künstler haben so eine andere
einstellung wie ist ich komme nicht aus
dem künstlerischen freiheit tatsächlich
hat der gastronomie oder im hotel und
ich bin sehr strikt seit 15 jahren
arbeitet luca caso im mainzer unterhaus
nie hätte er gedacht dass hier einmal
ein spendenaufruf produziert wird die
unvorhersehbarkeit macht alles zu einer
herausforderung das haus lebt vor allem
vom ticketverkauf lange im voraus
doch der ist massiv eingebrochen
trotzdem sitzt michael esser täglich
drei stunden an seinem angestammten ort
mehr fehlen meine kunden also ich meinen
rufen auch abends immer welche an und es
kommt auch mal jemand vorbei also
verkaufte es er gar nicht bis ganz wenig
was sehr schade ist auch nicht weil wir
sind jetzt bis sommer nächsten jahres im
verkauf mit unseren karten ein blick auf
das programm im september 20 21 gähnende
leere im hauptsaal meine größte angst es
hat keine karte gekauft und wir müssen
die veranstaltungen absagen ja also ich
meine wenn wir jetzt im dezember hätten
veranstalten müssen hätten wir
wahrscheinlich eher die hälfte absagen
müssen weil keiner kommt die leute sind
so verunsichert mittlerweile dass es
sich gar nicht mehr vor die tür trauen
was man nicht unterschätzen darf ist
tatsächlich wir haben jetzt geschlossen
aber wenn wir für januar nicht
vorbereiten sind wie januar auch
geschlossen
also muss ich schauen das ist alles bis
für januar fit habe und am start habe
dass wenn wir aufmachen dürfen wie auch
alles da haben
finale einstellungen für das spenden
video am späten abend dass es spät wurde
ist für alle kein problem sondern
ehrensache damit dem unterhaus im
nächsten jahr nicht alle lichter
ausgehen
spende
hätte baby danke für die socken be nice
doch künstlerinnen stehe nicht auf den
scheiß no no wir brauchen nur drei
monate liquidität und nicht wie du ohne
diät